hi so a lot of people on this one pretty
much the whole laws family has joined
you guys must really like this episode
this is Bree by the way for those who
don't know she's been a few videos to
she's in the demo real and suburban
nights also right yeah get in that um so
yeah a huge adventuretime fan right yeah
yeah yeah super huge she was also the
hands you saw grab his glasses last time
under stunt hand yes she's the stunt man
which now I get so and a week I know
that by watching city of thieves uh this
is an episode where you got Jake and
Finn they come across this town where
everyone steals everything and there's
this tree lady that's in a way I can
describe where that just comes out of a
tree and says don't turn you into a
thief and they don't believe in they see
this little girl that says was it her
vascular stolen yes and that you have to
go into the city of thieves to get it
back and she says but there's this tall
tower that only a pure heart can get the
stuff in and maybe my basket is there
you just have to take it from the master
of Thieves so he goes and takes it and
becomes a thief that way and didn't feel
so terrible and dirty that he goes and
tries to get vengeance I thought oh girl
I guess but the vengeance is making her
purify cleaning her up apparently and
they in turn become very clean
themselves so even though she steals his
clothes at the end so basic episode
pretty funny
I love the animation when they're
stealing everything and because it goes
on for like a couple of minutes I mean
just everybody's always taking something
a certainly neat design upon deep design
and just a good energy and a good pacing
to it sounds like the design of that
tree lady - does she have a name I don't
know just tree witch thing okay what
Congress and you know we're gonna have a
bunch of people going know
and yeah just basic kind of fun episode
I'm not gonna say much because I have a
three-headed monster here so what do you
guys have to say oh I I just wanted to
say like anytime you see like a cartoon
or a show or they say oh this is a city
of thieves are like everyone kind of
steals there's always still that
separation of here are the thieves and
here the people that are being preyed
upon and in this city of thieves no
everyone is actually a thief yeah the
guy breaks out steals the baby who in
turn steals the jewel from inspection
from his - yeah love the baby steals
it's one of those where no it's
literally a city of thieves where
everyone is actually a full-on thief and
no one's actually being preyed upon
because they're all preying upon each
other
I would actually point out I did guess
that the penny girl was gonna be a thief
by the way I call that you no no she
just said she was afraid that's why she
couldn't go in I'm like but I didn't get
John that that would make him a thief
though I thought that was a clever twist
on that um so how about you Jerri
I thought it was actually really neat if
we're going by showing a little lesson
you know the idea of sometimes we do
things accidentally it's not that you're
a bad person you just do things
sometimes that don't necessarily turn
out to be quite as good as they should
be and I love the idea that penny you
know it's kind of that crap friend that
bad influences that mothers like to tell
their children about oh my god okay I
know she's the bad influence on other
friends you should know that mothers
speak of you to their children pictures
are on the wall stay away from you know
it she's kind of that bad influence
where she kind of tricks Ben and I and I
love in the end too which is probably
twisted but I love in the end we cleaned
you everything's fine we're perfect and
she's like oh yes you're right I'll
never do it again
and
way and she steals his clothes and it's
like yeah because people don't just turn
around James like that I mean it takes a
while oh yeah unless it sort of seems
like Finn and Jake was my fee Finn feels
he's turned around now when really what
he's done is not that bad yeah but but
for him see himself it's so pure and so
good you know he feels like this isn't
so terrible but ya know I agree the fact
that it shows that he sort of can for
him this is like he's done something so
awful so bad no you can it happens and
you can come back from it and still be
fine um and the other thing I really
like again about this show is talking
about how positive and upbeat you know
they always are I like the fact of how
much I mean now I are they very helpful
and they want to keep helping people out
but they're so they so enjoy I guess as
he always puts out pure he is and how
good he just loves good you know and he
you know to him good is awesome and it's
like the coolest thing and I just think
that so it I like the kids and people
get into that they just get into how
positive he is and just how he wants to
keep doing positive things and spreading
positive things because I think for
awhile like for a long time because the
characters in the past that were like
that weren't written very well but these
two are written very well and there are
a lot of fun and and they're they're
funny and they're kind of cool they're
they embrace her and they're dorkiness
and they're just like no we're gonna do
whatever you want we have adventures and
swords well what's wrong with that and
it just makes them a lot of fun and
enjoyable to watch so it's I think it's
great that they're so upbeat they're so
positive but they're also kind of cool
like you want to watch them it's not
like oh the what are the
stick-in-the-mud always has to do the
right thing they're actually enjoyable
and fun and like smart well I won't say
smart but like interesting characters
they can get the kids excited about
being cool they get the kids about being
good yes about being good it's like
great you don't have to be this boring
little loser that always just hopes
people around I mean it's not he's not a
goody two-shoes he's morally solid you
know but he's still he talks back to
adults he does all this kid stuff that
kids do all the time that kids wish they
could do
the time and that's okay it's it just it
is what it is that it's it's fun it's
okay you can still be cool and good time
what do you guess what what do you get
say something something you like about
this episode no but I see what mom says
about the whole like uh like the bed
yeah we heard what she said yeah that
influence I also sort of see the whole
like sometimes people just don't change
like once a thief always a thief like
penny I don't know I said yeah it's yeah
like what you were saying where it's
like you can't did you really think you
could change a person around that fast
like even thin when he changes it's
because he wants to change but penny
didn't want to change so she doesn't if
she just puts on a facade so yeah I
think I saw her what makes the big
difference is that Finn he feels he's
still something wrong he's in a bad spot
but he wants to get out of it yeah I
just love ho and you know he's like
we're Virgin Islands and the two cherubs
come down and then steal the source
comes out like to steal the sighs and
fly off I like that that's all i upstate
bye oh don't leave me laws no now all we
got the one I said I never come back